let's get to some Kerry Lake Insanity
Donald Trump recently said that we must
terminate parts of the Constitution to
either reinstate him we're talking about
2020 here reinstate him to the oval
officer have a completely new 2020
election even though it's almost 2023.
this was crazy and authoritarian and
dystopian and horrifying and Carrie Lake
who recently lost her Arizona
gubernatorial race but has a lawsuit and
is has prayers that she's using to try
to get in office she says Trump was
right to call for the termination of
parts of the Constitution yeah she's
auditioning really hard to be Donald
Trump's VP uh their values right the
Constitution above all else except
except here a massive voter fraud of
this type and magnitude
allows for the termination of all rules
regulations and articles even those
found in the Constitution our great
Founders did not want and would not
condone false and fraudulent elections I
agree with them on that whoa can you
imagine our founding fathers what they
went through to help bring about this
great nation seeing what happened in
2020. nothing happened the person who
got the most votes won it's really
seeing what's happening now in 2022 just
saying okay well I guess it didn't go
our way and I guess they cheated we know
they rigged the elections and they put
in a bumbling fool who doesn't even have
the mental capacity to run this country
okay just get over it we'll just let the
loser take the White House I don't think
that would happen president Trump is
saying we are in unprecedented times and
unprecedented measures are necessary
that is what he is saying right Carrie
Lake agrees with Trump terminate parts
of the Constitution now as a reminder
Donald Trump's full statement on Truth
social was quote and this was based on
the Twitter story okay quote so with the
revelation of massive and widespread
fraud and deception and working closely
with big tech companies the DNC and the
Democrat Party do you throw the
presidential election results of 2020
out and declare the rightful winner
or do you have a new election a massive
fraud of this type in magnitude allows
for the termination of all rules
regulations and articles even those
found in the Constitution our great
Founders did not want and would not
condone false and fraudulent elections I
spoke earlier this week to you with
peace and love about the unfortunate
reality that even their most prized
principles and values that they claim to
ascribe to almost like sacred texts the
Constitution Free Speech not regulating
businesses you although okay you know
them they abandoned them at the drop of
a hat at the drop of a pin
if it's not convenient and right now
that sacred text to them the
Constitution
is uh nothing
it's toilet paper that you flush 10 or
15 times depending on the type of
Plumbing that you have how long is this
going to be accepted or even just looked
the other way at by a large portion of
these right Wingers I think for a long
time because they're all part of it they
all don't really care about their values
if the values are no longer convenient
and by the way how long are people going
to keep interviewing Carrie Lake Fox
News often bills her as former Arizona
gubernatorial candidate yeah but okay
she ran a race and she lost for how long
does that keep getting you interviewed I
don't know the answer just asking
questions
the science tells us that one of the
best ways to get consistent deep sleep
is lowering your core body temperature
when your body stays cooler at night
you're more comfortable and your sleep
is better our sponsor sleep me is the
home of chili sleep the customizable
climate controlled sleep solutions that
can improve your sleep by keeping you
cooler at night there are three
different chili sleep systems there's
the uler the cube and the new Doc Pro
with double the cooling power all three
systems are water-based temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
you with your ideal sleep temperature
you can go as cool as 55 degrees you can
go really hot if you want I keep mine at
60 beautiful temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night